over 50 years of shows picking a hundred
episodes to save out of all the
available options trying to get it all
done in one video let's get to work
[Applause]
[Music]
all right folks I have been meaning to
get to this for a little while now
because I was tagged in this sort of
assignment thing by the Doctor Who guy
great Channel if you have never checked
out the Doctor Who guide please do that
but what this is is this is a challenge
to select 100 Doctor Who episodes to
save so like the premise of the thought
exercise is every Doctor Who episode
except for the 100 that that you select
or in this case I select gets wiped from
existence you can't save them in any way
not like Oh last episode we have audio
and can it no it's gone
everything except these hundreds are
gone and and in disregard to how I
normally treat these things each
individual episode counts as an episode
so in modern era doctor if you're
talking two-parter each half counts as
an episode you do the whole story that's
two episodes you go to classic who you
start getting into three parts stories
four parts three six eight every single
part of that counts as an episode so
with that is the basis this is my
selection and let me emphasize very
quickly that quality of the episode is
not the only thing I am putting into
play and considering as a criteria for
having an episode be included on this
list I will try and explain as briefly
as I can why I put on here what's on
here but let's go I'm going through
these in chronological order in terms of
airing because that's just the easiest
way to deal with it
so first up the unearthly child this
total no-brainer
absolutely it's lays out everything it
is one of the best openers to any show
especially any weird sci-fi II show
that's ever been done you have to have
it forget about the story that it leads
into we're jumping straight to the
Daleks now we're not saving every single
episode of the Daleks we are doing
episodes 1 to 6 and 7 because honestly
story drags in the middle so we're
cutting that out because we're not
losing too much and we get four episodes
of the Daleks next up for number six the
final part I believe it's Episode six of
Dalek invasion of Earth mainly just for
the doctors goodbye to Susan because
yeah it's worth saving just for that the
rest of the stories
good it actually might even be my
favorite first doctor story but it's not
as essential in terms of laying out the
foundation of what Doctor Who is and
having it's a propriety moving on from
there to parts from the time meddler the
last two specifically because honestly
the build-up to figuring out what's
going on not nearly as interesting once
the doctor starts going in the battle of
wits against the meddling monk now we're
talking next up we got to cover the
first regeneration it's kind of
important I'm not necessarily gonna have
every regeneration covered but we got to
have the first one in here
I mean it's so core to the whole thing
and it's important to have the initial
time the entire concept was done so that
means that we're gonna do the last
episode of the tenth planet and the
first episode of power of the Daleks
under current circumstances that would
be an animated recreation let's for the
moment assume that we can actually get
the real thing so now we're into the
second doctor's era and I'm I'm going
straight to tomb of the Cybermen all
four parts and yes you can make some
complaints about it but I do feel this
is quintessential second doctor he has
wonderful stuff going on a with Jamie
you have the Cybermen who are done
possibly the best they've ever been in
this particular story you've got
terrific lines some of the best lines
ever from Trouten you have not strictly
speaking based undersea story but it
still has that flavor so it it still
works very well as being representative
of the second doctors there as a whole
and I'm biased I just think it's the
best that thing that he was in now we're
gonna get to the wargames now we are not
taking a whole bunch of the war games we
are actually taking very little of the
war games we are taking episode three
because it's the introduction of the
sonic screwdriver and we're taking up so
10 because that is the first appearance
of Time Lords it also covers the
regeneration for the second doctor
Early's what sets it off up to number 17
and we're in two third doctor territory
and we're skipping his first couple of
episodes we are jumping to cause of
access episode for a lot of people
really like this story I have mixed
feelings about it I am due to revisit it
I'll grant that however I only really
want to preserve the fourth episode of
that because the interactions between
the doctor and the master
that episode wok gold and leading on
from that another episode or story
rather that is a great example of the
third doctor at his best plus does the
interaction with master wonderfully the
sea Devils and we're doing all six parts
of that for 24 and 25 getting us a
quarter of the way there we come to the
three doctors we're gonna do the first
part and the last part so episode one in
Episode four introduced the entire
nature of multi doctor stories and sort
of cover what happens with Omega at the
end of that and where things sort of
quote unquote go back to normal
next up all four parts of the time
warrior because it's really good night
eleven into the introduction of Sarah
Jane it's my personal favorite third
doctor story so yeah I'm biased so we're
up to Tom Baker now robot episode one
because he hits the ground running you
get the feel this doctor right off we
don't need the rest of this story those
are just that first episode next up
genesis of the Daleks let's get
controversial I'm not keeping this whole
thing I'm doing episode 1 episode 5 and
episode 6 we're gonna set up the entire
thing of Skaro we're gonna get our time
with Davros we're gonna have things like
Davros with you know his interaction
with the doctor with that whole would
you create a virus thing we're gonna
have the doctors whole existential
crisis of do I have the right we're
gonna preserve that stuff but whole
bunch of the middle we can Chuck cuz I
think it's overrated don't shoot me
next up pyramids of Mars episode 4 this
is another dr. Fourth Doctor story that
I tend to think is a bit overrated but
the actual confrontation when he finally
takes on su tech really good stuff he's
a good enemy the solution for beating
him is pretty neat keep it
next up good to show my bias against
city of death it's my favorite fourth
doctor my favorite classic who it might
even be my favorite Doctor Who story of
all time all four parts were keeping
that next up keep your tracking we're
not keeping the whole story but we are
keeping the crispy master dealing with
the doctor and his taking over at Remus
for his new body which means we are
keeping episode 4 of that story so that
takes care of Tom Baker we're up to
Peter Davison and number 40 on our whole
countdown we're get to Castro valve um
we're gonna keep episodes 1 and episode
4 because I think the whole setup of
Castro valve is really neat I think
Ellucian of Castroville is pretty neat
the stop of the middle whilst by no
means bad I don't think is absolutely
essential to get what we need to out of
this story so just the front the back
next up earth shock episodes two three
and four drop episode one because
honestly it's a big lead-up to the
reveal of the Cybermen that kind of
really doesn't matter especially
considering that the story doesn't
really kick into gear until they get
introduced so scrapped Episode one keep
the next three because well it's a good
Cybermen story and companion dying have
a big deal next up the five doctors
because well because it was done as one
continuous thing it only eats up one
episode sure why the heck not it's kind
of monumental now this one's gonna be
weird for number 46 worries of the deep
episode 3 specifically for the murca and
if you're wondering why on earth would I
ever think we should preserve the murca
of all things it's because it's kind of
the visual storytelling a low point of
Doctor Who as a whole and arguably
helped get the show cancelled I think it
is actually kind of important if we're
gonna preserve the entirety of Doctor
Who to recognize that it wasn't always
gold and that this is how it could be at
the low point I only need one episode as
a point of reference for that but I
actually kind of think it should be
there so that brings us to caves of
Androzani final story for Peter Davison
keep the whole thing so that's four
episodes that gets us up through 50 and
we get to 51 and I like the vengeance on
virus I guess both parts so that Colin
Baker is at least represented because
otherwise he's not here all his best
stuff is in Big Finish but big finishes
and in play for this particular exercise
so that's the only way we get to
acknowledge him fine and we get to
Sylvester McCoy let's have a remembrance
of the Daleks all four parts of the
story because the story is great
we're also gonna have last episode of
survival because well that's how the
show went off the air for quite a chunk
of time so yeah let's have that on the
record
next up boy I was torn on this really
debated it the 1996 movie with Paul
McGann because again like it's not
perfect but like that was an attempt to
keep the thing going it was the main
your doctor who released for about 26
years I think we kind of need to
preserve it on that basis alone Plus
begins actually good so we're at number
59 and we have entered the modern era of
Doctor Who so under Eccleston let's
start out with end of the world I know
not everyone loves this one but honestly
I think it is a great encapsulation of
the mood and the tone of the revived
series in terms of the vibe of the
doctor himself his place in the world
the dangers rose you get a very good
sense of in it and the sort of the new
companion template and the various ands
or whatever I think it's a great
encapsulating episode so I think that
should be the kickoff for modern era in
terms of this preservation next up Dalek
I shouldn't even have to justify this
it's the return of the Daleks it's one
of the best Dalek stories so that is a
no brainer next up the empty child and
the doctor dance is brilliant two-parter
so good on so many levels it's creepy
it's scary it's funny introduction of
Jack Harkness ya know we're absolutely
keeping that and then parting of the
ways we are not keeping bad wolf because
we don't need it and it's not good and
now we're into Tennant's era forget
Christmas invasion don't care we're
gonna jump straight to school reunion
because this once actually aside from
just the nostalgia factor of seeing
Sarah Jane again it's actually really
important because it illustrates how the
show is still tied in to what it was
before plus it's a cracker of an
episodes anyway so that's easy next up
let's do girl in the fireplace actually
I don't love this as much of a lot of
other people do but I like the way that
the story unfolds it's got the feels for
a lot of people and that's worth
preserving next up we are going to do
impossible planet in the Satan pit
because I friggin love them and then
like and this is not an unbiased list
okay like at some points I'm putting a
more academic perspective on it
sometimes it's just like I really want
to be sure that gets saved and that's
gonna be it for those next up army of
ghosts and doomsday I debated whether or
not we could get away with just having
doomsday and not needing army of ghosts
but ultimately the build-up is kind of
necessary because otherwise we just
basically jump into the middle of the
climax of the story so we are gonna
preserve both of these large
for the fun of the Cybermen and the
Daleks together and also the tragedy of
rose up to number 70 human nature and
the family blood epic awesome creepy
romantic what's not to love
blink duh utopia and possibly
controversial not keeping the other
three parts of this John Simm original
master thing because I don't like it and
I don't think it's a particularly good
representation of the master as a
character nor is it a particularly good
series finale for series 3
but utopia that's great stuff it's a
good story in and of itself derek jacobi
you get a taste of what John Simm would
do with the character without being
stuck with him for entire episode so he
still gets his little taste in the thing
next up time crash yes I personally made
the choice to put the minisodes into
play and consider them as options so
that's why this is here it's a wonderful
celebration of a specific era the doctor
and again a bit like scurry and shows
these shows relationship to its earlier
iteration which I think has value aside
from the fact that it's a fun little
thing in and of itself
next up fires of Pompeii I actually
initially didn't think that I would have
included this but having recently we
walked rewatched it the empathy of Donna
and the way she kind of forces that onto
the doctor forces him to not be cold and
cruel and to take the damage I was going
on around and under consideration and
that and to realize that saving anybody
cells value even if you can't save
everybody that's important then it
matters and it's part of my Donna is
awesome so we keep it
next up science and library force the
dead it's fun it's funny it's got River
Song it's it's scary because it's got
the fashion neuron it's got a cool
concept it's gotten Donna being
heartbreaking it's got everything we
have it next up midnight frigging
terrifying and the most perfect
challenge for tennis doctor and he fails
let's see the doctor fail it needs to
happen every now and then here it is
nice we're gonna jump to journey's end
we are gonna skip the stolen planet
because unlike our me a ghost in
doomsday I do actually think we can get
away with
being into the second half of this and
that's where all the payoff is and with
the episodes I picked ahead at that time
I think the payoff still works
next up the 11th hour I would say quite
possibly the best opening story for
doctor for a new doctor it's it has a
terrific introduction for Amy
Smith's right on the ball it just hits
the ground running Vincent and the
doctor this is such a touching so Dan it
does just depression and suicide so
respectfully and so beautifully and so
tragically I mean this is just a amazing
piece of television that needs to be
preserved even outside of Doctor Who
fandom the Pandorica opens cuz what an
epic set up in a first half of a
two-parter we're not keeping big bang
though we're just gonna keep the set up
and let people imagine how that resolved
because whatever they come up with it's
gonna be more interesting than Big Bang
was that's right folks shots fired but
I'm moving on to the doctor's wife
because it's fun and entertaining and
shows a really good understanding of the
dynamic between the doctor and the
TARDIS we're gonna do the girl who
waited that is an underappreciated
episode and Karen Gillan is stunning in
it and shows the ruthlessness that the
doctor engages him because he feels he
has to it shows the pain of what it's
like and for the decisions he has to
make let's get to the god complex which
is a wonderfully layered dark
examination of the doctor and again the
sorts of things he tends to face very
underrated episode and I think is
brilliant matically night of the doctor
and the fact that I wanted to have the
night of the doctor is a big part of why
we have the 1996 Doctor Who movie
because this doesn't pay off well unless
we also have that so honestly yes that's
getting dry going just cuz I want
neither the doctor so dang much Dave the
doctor I know feeling people are a lot
our pretty mixed on this but it's the
50th anniversary it gives us the war
doctor it is a love it or hate it it is
a celebration of Doctor Who as a whole
and I think should be preserved and we
are into Capaldi's era so let's keep
mummy on the Orient Express because it's
just really good death in heaven which
is under
as us as a series finale and it has some
really great interactions between Missy
and the doctor and then we go to the
Saigon inversion basically just for that
speech we do the one-two punch of face
the Raven and heaven-sent tragic loss
dealing with that loss and the the pain
of grief and overcoming that
metaphorically through breaking down
that wall and you better believe we are
not having hell-bent oxygen because I
think it's a really solid episode with
some cool things to say and I like the
way the themes are handled I know some
people get uppity about this one I think
it's really good and a fun story besides
and Plus you know consequences doctor
goes blind like for a little while
that's kind of important extremis I feel
like this one kind of gets
underappreciated because of its tie to
the the two-parter that comes after it
but I do think this holds and stands
alone on its own and it takes a core
premise that sounds like well whatever
the answer is it's not gonna work but it
actually does and it works quite well
and plus we get to see again the fact
that the blindness lasted for a bit
let's have the consequences stick I like
it here we are folks five more episodes
to go and I'll be out of numbers next up
world enough in time and the doctor
falls world enough in time because it's
the Mondas Cybermen done better than
basically anything outside of possibly
spare parts and spare parts is Big
Finish so it's not on the table so let's
have this cuz it's creepy and it is I
love Missy innit I love the doctor in it
like yeah we're gonna do this
and the doctor falls I think is a much
better send off for Capaldi's doctor
than twice upon a time and even kind of
like twice upon a time but not enough to
preserve it so that does mean sorry
haters we are gonna have some Whitacre
episodes on this list first up Rosa and
yes if you've seen my videos talking
about Rosa I have very complicated
feelings about this story however I will
not deny its power and its ability to
drive a conversation and I think it
works very much as a mission statement
for what the
was trying to do at this period and time
and again love it or hate it it's this
needs to serve as a preservation of what
the show is and has been at various
points ROS some matters on that front
but then we get to the two episodes that
I think are actually the best episodes
of series 11 so that we can round out
this list first up that gives us demons
of the Punjab because it deals with a
piece of history that the kind that the
kind of people who either make or watch
doctor who aren't particularly familiar
with but honestly we should be and again
feels a very much natural progression
off of Rosa and it takes you away best
episode of series 11 best episode that
Whitaker has been in as of time of this
recording it is weird and bizarre and
sublime and I freaking love it and that
is 100 woo I could have easily made this
video an hour or more and gone into like
really exhaustive detail on each of
these entries because I've spent
actually quite a while putting this list
together but I honestly just had a lot
more fun rattling through them as
quickly as I felt they could get away
with so that's my list of a hundred
episodes to save and preserve from
Doctor Who from its original airing in
1963 up through 2019 beginning of 2019 I
don't know if we'll end up with the
special icon Christmas or something they
haven't announced it but who knows but
yeah that's my list of 100 I'm not gonna
tag any other people in this project
because I didn't do the legwork to
figure out who else might have already
been tagged by other people and I also
feel like I kind of missed the window
and you know from when this thing was
going but anyone who sees this who wants
to take on the challenge by all means go
for it even if I don't name you consider
you consider yourself invited to join in
this little project so whatever your
thoughts are on my list your list if you
only want to do a top 10 or whatever you
want to do a full hundred whatever you
want to do drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's the
patreon down there which helps actually
cover my bills at this point also
there's other stuff down there besides
click on
the links take you places check them out
or don't I'm not gonna tell you what to
do because at the end of the day you are
the council I'm just running the
meetings so until next time this council
is churned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]